I remember you telling me about the weak
Pawn true now I see a white Pawn on E6
and I sort of like how did white get a
white Pawn on E6 in this position well
we're about to find out here we go I
like this Knight kind of movement F1 E3
to improve it yes but aren't you walking
into
F4 are you oh wow so that's two pieces
for a rook tell I don't like that move
anymore no too late you already did it
oo that was a really tat is taking over
look it's like everything is hanging
here it just blew up oh but come on this
Pawn on C3 is so massively strong you
would love to involve your queen into
play but from A1 unfortunately
everything is covered I will have to go
Queen B1 Queen H7 but Queen B1 The Rook
is there yeah the queen is is trapped
trapped yeah